lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
graficar la desigualdad menos 14 x menos
7 y menor que 4 y como siempre pausa e
intenta llegar a la solución bien la
forma en la que quiero obtener esto es
despejando ayer de una parte de la
desigualdad y lo voy a hacer en el lado
izquierdo así que lo primero que voy a
hacer es pasar este menos 14 x del otro
lado y la mejor forma de hacerlo es
sumar 14 x de ambos lados ya que si lo
hago del lado izquierdo también lo tengo
que hacer del lado derecho y esto me
llevará a que se cancelen estos dos y me
quedan menos 7 james menor que 14 x más
4 o 4 más 14 x es lo mismo y ahora voy a
querer dividir de ambos lados por menos
7 para despejar allí pero hay que ser
muy
y muy cuidadosos con esto ya que cuando
multiplicamos o dividimos una
desigualdad por un número negativo
necesitamos voltear el signo de la
desigualdad es decir si tenemos el signo
de menor que éste va a pasar a ser el
signo de mayor que al dividir por menos
siete así que si dividimos de ambos
lados por menos 7 vamos a obtener que es
mayor que y es más déjame ponerlo con
otro color para hacer más énfasis james
va a ser mayor que 14 entre -7 que es
menos 2 - 2x menos 4
séptimos 4 entre menos 7 es menos 4
séptimos y ahora estamos listos para
graficar la y la forma en la que vamos a
hacer la gráfica es primero fijarnos en
la recta de igual a menos 2 x menos 4
séptimos esta recta ponerla punteada
porque no tenemos un mayor o igual y
después sombrear todo lo que esté por
arriba de ella así que déjame hacerlo
para que lo entiendas y veas mejor de
que te estoy hablando primero vamos a
dibujar unos ejes por aquí por aquí
tengo a mi eje y y por acá me voy a
dibujar a mi eje x y veamos tenemos por
aquí al menos uno por aquí al menos dos
por aquí voy a poner al 1 y en x aquí
pongo al 1 y por aquí voy a poner al 2
así que primero vamos a trazar a la
recta
james igual a menos 2 x menos 4 séptimos
déjame escribirla
vamos a trazar la recta james igual a
menos 2 x menos 4 séptimos eso es lo que
vamos a hacer primero si nos fijamos en
esta recta tenemos una intersección con
el eje y de menos 4 séptimos que es un
poquito más que menos un medio entonces
vamos a estar como por aquí y después
tenemos una pendiente de menos 2
entonces si crecemos en 1 en x entonces
vamos a decrecer en 2 en game es por eso
que más o menos por acá pasamos esto más
abajo y por ejemplo tenemos nuestro
segundo punto y ahora con nuestra
herramienta de la regla vamos a dibujar
a esta recta y recuerda no buscamos la
gráfica de e iguala esta recta queremos
graficar el área solución de esta
desigualdad a mayor que por lo tanto
pondré una recta punteada porque ojo no
vamos a incluir la gráfica de la recta
de igual a menos 2 x menos cuatro
séptimos entonces pongamos una
punteada y buscamos todas las equis
james que sean más grandes que esta
recta de nuevo quiero ser muy claro en
esto aquí tengo en la gráfica de la
recta que igual a menos 2 x menos cuatro
séptimos pero la puse punteada porque no
le incluyen esta desigualdad no tenemos
un símbolo de mayor o igual o un signo
de igual fíjate es simplemente el
símbolo de mayor que y ahora para dar la
solución que queremos tenemos que
fijarnos en toda el área por arriba de
esa recta así que vamos a sombrear la
todo esto no incluimos la recta pero si
todos los puntos que estén arriba de
ella y qué creés ahora hemos acabado